but now I want to find out a minimum
rather than deal with its by the way
those of you who have made some headway
to this will find there's no problem
with doing this okay
it just is much longer and more
error-prone there's no reason why I
can't compile a just deal with this guy
the maximum sorry the minimum for this
will be the same as the minimum for this
okay so therefore my first step is
differentiate or my differentiating a be
square that's the function right I know
it looks a little bit awkward but I can
call functions whatever I like I called
Y or s for P or a B squared it's just a
name for me right they're both going to
be functions in T so I can differentiate
them with respect to take with respect
to time okay so that's just this part I
mean here it looks to me like a million
minus 112 plus 60 40 yes now I want you
to find what I want to find what was the
point of doing that I want turning
points right turning points on a math
dollar okay so I'll say turning points
may exist because I don't actually know
yeah I'm just solving for the duty of
thing 0 may exist when that's 0
okay so this is really easy it's just a
straight line okay now why aren't I
doing another square here and the reason
why is how many times have I
differentiated it's up once first
derivative right and don't be confused
it's a squared up here but that's
because that's what the function is I
could just as easily have said you know
what forget that this is a Dobby or
squared or anything just call that and
just call it X just call anything you
like
it's just a function right and it
happens to do what I wanted to that
behavior and exhibits is exactly that
behavior I'm trying to test but it is
actually called a B Smith so I have no
reason to give any label to it okay so
let's think about this oh I did kind of
mention this before but I will just show
you quickly on the diagram right because
my diagram is so wonderfully awesome
okay let's just track this through time
after one hour right I would be here and
here they're both got four kilometers
closer is that okay
now at the second hour eggs the guy and
a with a reached earth right but the guy
V will have gone past own all right so
the distance was that for the first hour
minutes this for the second hour do you
see that so they never actually collide
because they started different points
and travel the same speed there's always
gonna be some different lamination so
for instance they can start the same
distance away but one could be traveling
faster than the US and they're never
actually going to collect all right so
this is a nice easier than you function
to solve there it is right there so I'm
going for minus 112 T sine plus 64 t0
someone already worked out the other one
775
1 and 3/4 there by the way just as usual
we use a sense check on this right just
this something about life I just very
slowly reverse for you ok at 1 out of it
here and then at 2 now is there here
1.75 hours is somewhere in between
that does sound a bad one it's sort of
around the time when he's getting
closest to here you'll get there in two
hours
now where is this tire has just gone
past it's just not hot he takes one of
my house
ok so very good so you've gone a step
further because I'm not quite there
right
hence find when when there's my odds on
to win after 1 and 3/4 hours an hour and
45 minutes and where the men are nearest
to each other so I'm going to take this
and where do I put it where do I put
this time
ok now interestingly right usually we're
so used to just I'll just put this back
into the function that you
differentiated which is this function
but the question is not asking that it
doesn't say how far are the men from
each other at that point you see how
important is to read the rest it's a
simple thing right I actually want to
know where they are
that's these numbers ok so when I've got
7 over 4 here because it's all over for
this is really easy this will be 8 minus
7 which is 1 right and this one will be
6 take away 7 now that's negative 1
which means he's over here he's gone
past right because my distance here is
east so he will have been you'll be on
the west side ok so I guess my answer
would be therefore after one it's
recorded hours sorry my table uses a
disaster that's my time a will be and
you've got to put it all in terms of
like they've given you berries right
north and east and so on so I'm gonna
say a will be actually set the name of
guy or is that the name of the point to
men
after that time one man will be one man
will be one kilometer north on earth and
the other will be what did we say he's
going past right the other will be one
kilometer west because he's gone past so
there will be the square root of two
kilometers away from each other
done so just to tie this up there are a
few things that we noticed a couple of
twists and turns right number one the
way is gracious what question is
everything right if you phrase your
question poorly you can't really
progress you can't access the question
until you know what's what right now
that you've seen this kind of question
before you will never have this trouble
with this particular page right but
later on you'll be like what how do I
even start this question that's often
the trickiest part read very carefully
don't don't worry yourself into the
first time you construct the question I
don't think there's anything wrong with
drawing this diagram you just realize
the street you're drawing it okay well
this is not enough I need to progress on
to something else and sometimes the
subunits doesn't arrive in your head
until you've read to the end of the
question and that's fine
secondly be aware of what you're
differentiating and why okay take
advantage of things like this I probably
would have said up here minimizing the
distance is the same as minimizing the
square of the distance
therefore I'm just gonna work with this
square the distance I'm not worried
about something to the power of 1/2 and
change moment of course okay and then
from there just be careful with your
interpretation like go back to the
question what are they actually asking
for don't just blindly take your number
pop back in whatever function you
started with pay attention to whether
that's actually what they're interested
in in whether whether answer the
question alone okay any questions any
person that will report move on yeah
Jack itself I want to hear this question
so I'll ask for your courtesy very good
okay that's a great question here there
is no there's no main restriction on
time apart from the fact that we extreme
times positive like you know it's not a
point in figuring about negative time
anyway because they're just getting
further away from each other so what's
the point
you're not gonna find a stationary point
over there but you're exactly right it's
like well time can be anything right
however that's one of the helpful things
I figured this guy right this guy here
this function you have a look at what
kind of function it is right you're
going to be this is gonna be a quadratic
right well at least the distance squared
will be a quadratic so at some point
right you hit a bit of a okay sorry I
shouldn't actually be above the axis
because it's positive but then you'll
never ever come back so even if there's
no endpoint the behavior beings in here
is trivial right I'm never gonna get a
minimum no matter how far I go right so
that's actually the advantage to you
because there's no end point you test
you know have to worry about an end
point at this point I actually would
have finished I should have said even
though they haven't asked for it I would
have determined the nature of this but
this is super easy to differentiate it
again
so you find okay there's the second
derivative 6464 is positive which means
it's concave up which means it's a
minimum so I have justified fairly
confidently that I have a okay but yeah
you you don't get often with these time
questions right um there isn't anything
apart from I guess I would say positive
time okay
sometimes you you look carefully all of
these questions I actually have a very
similar like a crossroad question is
very very common and there are lots of
different variation
are there other ones like this he's a
classic one about treatment you guys are
seeing the classic ones like this you've
got a a guy and he's um he's in a kayak
or a raft or something like that I would
see okay so he's here okay he's at the
yacht right and he has to get to some
point on the beach right now he has
Wilbur
he has two choices there's no choice
it's got no choices he can go straight
to shore and then he can walk across he
could do that right or alternatively he
could sail straight there or he could do
some combination for example he could
sail to some point here and then he
could walk now the question would be
this again would be a minimum right it's
not as hard as it looks in fact it's
just a variation on this question it's
still Pythagoras you see this and then
you say well based on the speeds that he
can sail at this is the speed he can
walk at then you can work out where the
minimum or maximum is not in this case
look carefully look carefully what would
be the variable what's he what's he
changing what can he you know there's
lots of good ways to say this but what
might you say is one example in the
feminine yeah okay where is he where's
he gonna go on to shore right so for
instance if I'm you know let's put some
numbers on this okay so suppose he is
for comment as a terrible choice of
colors sorry
I'm it's suppose he's four kilometers
perpendicular from the beach and that
point there is made under five
kilometers away from the poor he
actually needs to get to
okay now what am i varying its where do
I land where do I land on the beach okay
so I could land here
wiper then here or here or here or
anywhere along in this space okay so you
need to introduce a parameter you can do
this variety of ways right I mean the
first way that comes off at my mind
because the way I phrased the question
is I might say let's call this point
here let's call it zero right he lands
here zero is the actual variable and
then you can work out how much time that
takes okay but he can land at any point
from zero up until one or two or three
or four or five right that's the maximum
of the parameter okay now you can
differentiate you may find a stationary
point but then look there are very well
defined end points for this domain right
and you need to test them because they
might be the minimum as well depends on
what kind of stationary point you're
fine